THEY ARE CRATERING.
YOU SHOULD BE GIVING THEM
ADVICE, NOT THE OTHER WAY
AROUND?
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION IS
HISTORIAN VICTOR DAVIS HANSON,
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION.
ALL RIGHT, USUALLY HEAVY ON ON
THE MORNING.
ON THE RADIO.
WE HAVE YOU NOW.
YOUR REACTION TO THE ANGLE AND
WE WILL GET TO OTHER TOPICS.
>> I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE INVERSE OF WHAT THE
SO-CALLED DEEP STATE
ESTABLISHMENT SAYS.
THEY SAY THE POST WHERE -- THIS
GUY CAME IN WITHOUT PRIOR EXPERE
GUY CAME IN WITHOUT PRIOR EXPERC
GUY CAME IN WITHOUT PRIOR EXPER.
WHAT IF IT WAS THE OTHER WAY
AROUND.
IT WAS CHAOTIC AND DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE.
WHAT IF HE CAME IN AND SAID THIS
IS RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
THESE INSTANCES YOU POINTED OUT,
WHETHER IT WAS THE CRAZY OPEN
BORDER OR THE KNOT WITH THE GUNS
AND THE MISSILES.
WHETHER IT WAS NATO MEMBERS.
ON AND ON.
SYRIA, TO REPLY, HE'S GOT A LOT
OF DILEMMAS.
HE DIDN'T CREATE THIS SITUATION.
RUSSIA WAS BROUGHT IN AFTER 40
YEARS BY SUSAN RICE AND
JOHN KERRY AND THEY ASSURED US
THERE WERE NO WMDs.
SUSAN RICE SAID THAT LAST YEAR.
TRUMP COMES IN AND THERE IS WMD
AND WE'VE LOST ALL SENSE OF
DETERRENCE BECAUSE OF THIS
LEAVING BEHIND.
HE DOESN'T WANT AND CAN'T GET
INVOLVE THE WAY WE DID IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ.
HE IS IN BETWEEN THOSE.
EVERYBODY WHO WAS SUSPICIOUS OF
GOING IN THERE WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO SUPPORTED TRUMP FOR JUST THE
REASONS YOU SAID.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET ANGRY
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING
TO SEE IT AS A BETRAYAL.
ON THE OTHER HAND, ALL THE
PEOPLE PUSHING HIM FORWARD ARE
NEVER GOING TO VOTE FOR HIM.
THEY DESPISE HIM.
A NO-WIN SITUATION.
>> Laura: HE IS IN A BOX.
>> GOT TO FIND A WAY TO RESTORE
DETERRENCE WITHOUT GETTING
INVOLVED AND THAT'S HARD TO DO.
>> Laura: ADAM KINZINGER,
CONGRESSMAN, WE INVITED HIM ON.
HE WAS ASKED TODAY ABOUT WHETHER
CONGRESS SHOULD GIVE ITS,
MILITARY ACTION IN SYRIA.
>> I THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DID A YEAR AGO IN DESTROYING ONE
FIFTH OF ASSAD'S AIR FORCE WAS
GOOD.
IT WAS RIGHT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DO THAT
AGAIN.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SAY ANY USE
OF MILITARY FORCE IS GOING TO BE
WORLD WAR III OR IT'S GOING TO
MEAN 300,000 TROOPS IN SYRIA.
IT ISN'T.
>> DOES THAT PRESIDENT NEED TO O
>> DOES THAT PRESIDENT NEED TO E
TO CONGRESS?
>> Laura: THAT'S CONVENIENT
FOR CONGRESS.
THEY ARE NOT ON THE HOOK IF
STUFF GOES AWRY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT CONGRESS
DOES.
THEY ARE AGAINST SOMETHING AND
THEY SAY YOU HAVE TO COME.
THEY ARE AGAINST IT AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO.
WHAT TRUMP HAS TO DO AND HE HAS
GOOD ADVISORS.
I SLEEP SOUNDLY TONIGHT BECAUSE
OF THAT.
THEY ARE ADVISING HIM THAT WE
HAVE TO STOP THIS IDEA YOU CAN
HIJACK U.S. BOAT OR SEND A
MISSILE AT A U.S. CARRIER OR
POINT NUCLEAR WEAPONS BUT WE
CAN'T GO IN AND TRY TO
NATION-BUILDING MAKE THEM LIKE
CARMEL CALIFORNIA.
BETWEEN THAT, WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
THERE IS NO WAY TO SHOCK THE
RUSSIANS IN SYRIA AND SWEDEN
LOOKED TO GET IN THERE ON THE
GROUND BUT IT'S NOT EASY.
WE'VE GOT TO ASCERTAIN WHETHER
THERE WAS WMD.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SAID
CHLORINE DOESN'T COUNT.
THAT WAS THE FIRST GAS USED,
WORLD WAR I.
IT'S NOT REALLY WMD SO WE WERE
RIGHT SO WE'VE HAD NOTHING BUT
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE STATUS
OF WMD GOING BACK TO THE IRAQ
WAR.
WE HAVE TO ASCERTAIN, DID THEY
USE WMD ENDED THEY KILL INNOCENT
CHILDREN?
DID THEY BREAK THEIR WORD TO THE
RUSSIANS AND THE SYRIANS.
IF IT DOES, WE HAVE TO SEND A
MESSAGE AND WE HAVE TO DO IT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WE DON'T.